prime minister Vision soon actually just
simply said no when he was handed that
list by his predecessor Boris Johnson he
should have said well the Privileges
committee is still coming to its
findings I'm not going to pass through
any of these honors until I know the
outcome of the Privileges committee and
if the Privileges committee says as it
did that you lied to Parliament on many
occasions and even to be stripped now of
any association with Parliament then I'm
not going to put your your honors
through I think that's what leadership
is that's what I would have done and I
think I imagine many people watching
this would say well that was obviously
the right course but of course we've got
a prime minister that just gave in and
signed the list off and the idea now
that to other people dancing and
partying in that video are going to get
honors because the Prime Minister was
too weak to do anything about it I think
is yet another thing that's very very
hard for people to stomach